So let's talk about approximation quality.
Because, obviously, even though you've decided that you're content with a solution that is not optimal,
you still want to ensure a certain quality of your solution.
And we'll be looking at 2 different types of approximation algorithms in this unit.
The first 1 is called a constant factor approximation.
And what a constant factor approximation is, well, as the name says,
there is some constant C, so when you have an optimization problem
where you want to minimize some quantity,
this algorithm will guarantee you a solution that is no worse than C x the best possible solution.
For a minimization problem, your solution will be
≤ C x the optimum, or the best possible solution.
And that is a guarantee that this constant factor approximation gives you.
So this is for minimization, and for maximization--so minimization problem
you're trying to find this point here; for maximization problem, you're trying
to find this point here, basically.
Your solution is at least as good as 1 over C x the optimum.
So let's do a quick quiz to practice this.
So say you have a factor-2 approximation algorithm,
which means that C = 2.
So you have a factor-2 approximation algorithm for vertex cover.
You run the algorithm on an input, and it returns to you a vertex cover of size 100.
And, of course, this is a correct answer, so it is, indeed, a vertex cover,
we just don't know if it's the smallest possible vertex cover
because we're using an approximation algorithm.
What I would like you to tell me now is 2 things:
First of all, what is the maximum number of vertices in an optimum solution,
and please enter your answer here, and what is the minimum number
of vertices in an optimum solution? And please enter this number here in this box.